awards are funny you know
you can always find ten thousand reasons
why you don't deserve them and i can
find twenty thousand
i i do have a purpose and i appreciate
the purpose of the people and
an intention to do the right thing and
do well and to contribute to society
beyond
just paying taxes michael j fox is being
honored for his advocacy work in finding
a cure for parkinson's the debilitating
disease he was diagnosed with at the age
of 29. the emmy winner is set to receive
the aarp purpose prize award through a
virtual ceremony on december 15th
prognosis is very vague um with
parkinson's said like the guy so the
doctor told me i had 10 years left to
work and and i thought well if i only
only have a couple years left of
work i like
input something to give and i should
give it now to to to what is really
important
michael j fox was first diagnosed when
he noticed a twitch in his left little
finger while he was working on the set
of the 1991 film doc hollywood by the
end of that year he launched the michael
j fox foundation for parkinson's
research and poured all of his efforts
into its work when we uh got going in
20 20 years ago i just finished the show
spin city and we hunkered down in this
office that i refused to leave
and and
built the early stages of the foundation
like we wanted to we wanted to raise
money and use it so we said no endowment
and we said their other model was pure
purity emotive we just wanted to hear
parkinson's i've heard some scientists
say that by the time for example my
symptoms were evident
my pinky twitch
like 75 of my dopamine producing cells
was already dead
so we can if we get that we need that
early on if we can make it a standard
test that you do
uh
where they say
you you you have an indicator
of parkinson's and i mean it'll be great
so we're we're moving in on that after
being launched the michael j fox
foundation for parkinson's research has
funded more than one billion dollars in
global research programs fox currently
sits on the foundation's board of
directors and travels to speak on behalf
of the organization 20 years or 15 years
ago i couldn't have sit still for this
long
the fact that there are better drugs and
and and more effective treatments for a
lot of the side effects and in other
aspects of the condition is that i
point to us
in terms of
why some of that stuff happened